pierre complètement atomisé le marché du
jouet et qui investit cette année encore
le château de cheverny pour une grande
expo dédiée aux fables de la fontaine
laura cadeau ce que tu connais les
fables de la fontaine non des lego tu
connais alors plus de succès pour les
lego visiblement cette année les
célèbres briques investissent les pièces
et les couloirs du château de cheverny
et revisitent à leur manière les fables
de jean de la fontaine la cigale et la
fourmi
c'est en fait signal qui a chanté tout
l'été
la sig a chanté tout l'été
[Musique]
réciter sa poésie l'exercice semble
périlleux place aux révisions donc avec
cette exposition qui repose sur la
reproduction de tableaux de saynètes et
de sculptures d'animaux à taille réelle
l'occasion de revoir ses classiques
comme le corbeau et le renard
une des femmes les plus emblématiques
tous les enfants l'ont après chacun est
capable m à l'âge adulte dans récitait
une partie la morale tout flatteur vit
au dépend de celui qui l'écouté
et ça les enfants ont bien compris il
est très venteux le corbeau et bailly et
commence à chanter et quand ils ouvrent
le bec et le renard se précipite sur le
fromage
au total plus de cent cinquante mille
briques à assembler pour recréer
l'univers du xviie siècle de quoi faire
rêver les plus grands fans de lego
j'adore j'adore comme ils sont
construits et je suis fasciné par les
pièces c'est vrai que ça va par là de
monoko qui l ego les fables de la
fontaine il les apprennent à l'école